good morning believe nation today's
message is get back up over to you allen
iverson when I leave out of the crib
everyday people always ask me you know
say to me you know what's up and I tell
them the same thing 99.9% of the time I
tell them the same fight different round
you know that's what it is you know this
is this world is a world title fight you
know what I mean and some rounds the
rounds are days and some some days you
won't get knocked down and some rounds
gonna be good so I'm gonna be bad but
the only thing that matters is getting
back up and fighting again so what do
you think well I think he's right
because you know there's nothing better
than getting up what are you gonna do
stay down that's that's what someone
doing if they don't want to live anymore
so if you want to live longer you want
to but there's no better choice than
getting it because you only live once
you know Todd that I would say that your
mentality is really great and I think
that's an entrepreneur's mentality where
a lot of people don't see it that way
right they try one thing and they fail
at it and then they lose the courage to
ever try it again and they follow the
safe path and just because it didn't
work out the first time now is like oh
it's never gonna work out and then they
lived their life living for the weekends
and evenings and and not following their
dreams and even worse than like bringing
on other people you know because I
wasn't able to do it now your honor
- either I'm gonna suck you down my
negative vortex where if you look at the
history of any person who's achieved
anything major it's come with a lot of
setbacks a lot of failures right like
you try so that doesn't work you try
something again doesn't work there's
like each time you try it a little bit
differently you look at the history of
this YouTube channel go back you see a
lot of failures a lot of mistakes and I
think the thing that gets you through is
just the love of what you're doing like
I really want to make this happen and so
that pushes you through the fear and
through the insecurities and through the
failure because you just love doing it
so much so the questions that made today
is is there something that you have gave
up on and do you plan on getting back up
you planning any backup that's going
deep it's going to leave in the comments
below I'm curious to find out and I
think you'll probably get a lot of
encouragement from the other commenters
too to make sure you do get back up so
leave it below will join the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shut up and press